how we're feeling pumped yeah yeah Oh
way better all right let's do again are
we feeling pumped yes so thanks guys for
coming at nine o'clock really appreciate
it I got the worst slot but it's great
to see a good audience so what we're
going to do today it's to talk about
ankles I'm gonna introduce a lot of
fancy words in all HDFS
big data processing great for dinner
parties so that's gonna be useful
tutorials in that regard
and I'm gonna spend perhaps maybe twenty
minutes half an hour explaining some
concepts explaining the bigger picture
and then the remaining hour of this
tutorial should be very much hands-on so
I have a Python notebook we're gonna
write code and get to learn the SPARC
API so Cambridge spark and Apache spark
have nothing to do with one another it
just happens that we share the same word
spark but we're not affiliated to the
spark project but however I am a big fan
of spark generally so before I kick off
there's a few things to download and
links to type in your browser I'm gonna
explain what they are so accounts the
slides
here's a link so that you know when you
go home or later video we can you know
to refresh you have the material the
second dataset that we're gonna use
throughout this tutorial however the
coolest link of all of them it's the
third one I set this up yesterday
because I discovered google has his
service for google cloud which others do
tended notebook in the cloud with
everything set up so normally if you
just click on this and you'll see a link
so I'm just gonna click on that that's
the one you really want to click on so
I'm gonna click on it
and you should see something like that
so I'm the owner of this notebook so I'm
gonna go into incognito mode and I'll
put the link back on the screen in a sec
let's just so you see what's gonna
happen
so you're gonna see this and you should
be able to click on open in playground
it does require you to have a gmail
account or a Google account and what its
gonna do is you saw this notebook in
your jeans right and then you can play
all the code so that is all Java okay so
I'm gonna put the slides back home so
again you'll have to click on open in
playground once you signed in onto your
Google account so let me put this back
up so everyone can just download this
I'm sorry guys but you know I should
know I'd set up an environment over on
Windows used to click somewhere cool so
I'll give it the most three seconds so
take your photo in case you want to come
back to the slide in a bit
all right can I get some tums up for
those that have done it all right that
looks like quite a view so let's get
going so in that report is also manual
setup instructions if you want to set
things up on your laptop rather than on
the cloud so let me start with the
bigger picture Hey
okay and you want the wireless mics so
that we can get it on video as you walk
that way also oh sorry um either that or
we can because I'll be coding so
definitely okay I don't want to hold
them like in my head yeah sorry about
that and that should be working now yeah
okay all right one two we're good
alright guys so I'm going to spend maybe
20 minutes going from really high level
to low level explaining the landscape of
what big data is available technologies
and then focusing on batch processing
using Spock so I'll introduce a lot of
new words so before I get going you know
us a big data this is a say I mixed
money it sells is great for marketing
and sales so at Cambridge Park we
decided to go next level
we're gonna go humongous data you know
that's the new buzzword blockchain
compliant here we go humongous data it
is more realistically I want to shed
some light on why everyone's making a
first about you know data processing
generally and how do we scale that so
this is the context that we see you know
in the industry today right so storage
cost has decreased exponentially over
time so it's a commodity to store data
in the cloud it's really cheap on top of
that processing data is also commodity
now just in comparison to ten years ago
right we can get lots of CPU time on the
cloud and it's cheap
and finally the bandwidth is also cheap
so if I want to exchange data with
gentleman with the Hat
what's your name Anthony if I were to
exchange data of Anthony today it's
really cheap to do that over the
internet compared to just a few years
ago if you remember those modem they
were making his weird sound right so we
didn't have a lot of bandwidth and it
was expensive now as a result of all of
this you can see the odd one out
it's the the network graph there that
shows the number of interconnected nodes
on the internet that has increased
massively so we have a ton more devices
that essentially are producing data
there's really two store cheap to
process and cheap to exchange and that's
why the the tech industry has really
been revolutionized now to go a little
bit more technical and if I look at the
trend on the microprocessor evolution
then what we see really interestingly is
you know over time number of transistors
as you can see still increase over time
so that means we can do more work and we
can see the number of cores here is also
increasing so that's how we stack up
CPUs together to do go to collaborate to
solve a task so that's kind of good like
we see progress now you'll see like the
three other lines in the middle kind of
stagnating so how much power we can get
in the chip the frequency and the
instruction level parallelism or kind of
stagnating so that means we can't get as
much performance as we could from just
one single core the trick that we've
been doing for you know over a decade
now and with comet eise's is to have
multiple core architecture now I think
this is really interesting because the
same principle that we have on a single
computer a single server that has
multiple cores is directly applicable to
distributed systems suddenly in order to
get better performance we have to
coordinate the work amongst multiple
cores on one machine or amongst multiple
machines if we go distribute
so conceptually it's the same idea and
that's something we have to work with as
developers and obviously there are new
technologies is going to help us
facilitate this work whether it's multi
processing or what is distributed
processing so the context we have is we
have a lot more data we're cheaper
hardware but we're gonna have to go
parallel and distribute it to exploit
the latest hardware that we have so let
me spend a bit of time defining Big Data
and then I'm going to focus on one
specific class of problems in Big Data
called batch processing another
introduced the Hydra picker system now
if you're really interested in the
computer science fundamentals behind
distributed systems I really highly
recommend this book I'm not in Kaplan he
talks about all those kind of
engineering concerns that you might be
interested in like you know consistency
sharding no sequel database how they all
implemented the cap theorem so just
general good knowledge to to have as a
computer scientist now the volume just
to put things into perspective Facebook
has two billion users and conservatively
let's say like each user is making like
a one megabyte contribution of data per
day so you know Anthony do you like to
take yourself you know and then
sometimes right who doesn't so a good
selfie in high definition for a five
megabyte already so you know this is
very conservative right so just the
status or liking stuff one magnet of
metadata that's about two petabyte a day
and that's not even counting redundancy
so you know in case some server crashes
do I have some backups about the data of
our users so it's even more than this
right but just put things into
perspective there's clear challenges
with this amount of data my computer or
Anthony's computer's not gonna be good
enough to store all the selfies that
Facebook users produce every
a so we're gonna have to distribute the
data storage over several machines and
we're going to figure out how to process
this information over several machines
as well in a way that provides fault
tolerance in the case some machines goes
down so there's a lot of challenges now
to cope with the volume of data the next
concern is the velocity so that's about
the amount of information you receive
right now so when I speak to Anthony you
know you're receiving all this
information and you have to process it
like now in real time and again that
puts a lot of challenges from an
engineering point of view so for example
the CERN so particle collision detector
back in Europe boy recording 10 gigabyte
of data per second just kind of keep
track of particle collisions Twitter
indicated that they have 3,000 images
per second that they have to process
they're being treated around and what's
up you know 60 million message a day so
that's from a couple years ago so you
know it can probably multiply that by 10
I guess right so again from engineering
and processing point of view how do we
build an architecture or infrastructure
that's allowing us to cope with all this
information in real time it's
distributed over several machines and my
favorite one is the variety because
that's the one as a data scientist that
you see in practice so who's a fan of
excel raise your hand this is a safe
environment there's no shame you know
the doors are closed no one will know so
can I do some basic correlation here if
you love Excel keep your hands up do you
have Windows keep your hand up there you
go pretty much everybody well so I like
Excel as well right so something Excel
spreadsheets have done really well is a
conceptual model that is really simple
to interact with and understand right
the idea of having rows and columns
that's something everyone can relate to
it's easy to access information it's
easy to obtain it it's easy to read it
and relational databases you know that
came up in the SAP
these decades ago also built on this
model of having rows and n columns so
that's something that's easy to relate
to now the reality that we have today is
that not everything thing fits in to a
two-dimensional array or a table so
let's say you want to build a payroll
system that you know in New York
financial services are really popular
I'm just going to guess right so lots of
banks that have international offices so
you have a workforce that is maybe in
u.s. in Japan in China in Europe every
country has different rules when it
comes to taxes how you record
information about your employees are you
issue your payslip so can you think of a
unified schema that's gonna work for
every country in the world to build a
payroll system that's just not going to
be possible because you're gonna have so
many optional attributes so many null
values and when requirements change how
do you update that schema so two
dimension tables are not suitable for
those type of environments where
requirements are frequently changing not
only that you know graph structures are
becoming increasingly popular in terms
of processing so doing network analysis
for example whether it's social media
whether it's protein interaction if
you're into kind of chemistry and
biology or fraud detection who's
connected to who do we trust this party
so the data we have today is a lot
richer and has is a bit more difficult
to store in a two dimensional table
right so a graph how do you store down
to a table you can potentially make your
work but it's really inconvenient to
work with in query and that's the point
is that we need new technologies that
not only can cope with volume and
velocity but allows us to be productive
when it comes to data processing with
data that comes in various shapes and
sizes now I've got a good and bad news
and the bad news is if you look at this
scary table each little logo is you know
one new technology one new database one
new fame that allows you to solve a
specific problem dealing with velocity
volume variety maybe all those three
things together or just one of them for
different domains so there's a ton of
stuff it's scary and spark so this is
like fine wooly right the spark logo is
somewhere here yeah let's spark so today
we're going to talk about spark but
there's a lot more going on so the good
news is if you have to be a big data
engineer a big day a consultant you can
make a lot of money because no one
understands it there's too much so
that's good from a career point of view
I think so that's a great justification
so I've given you the landscape now I'm
gonna drill down a little bit and focus
on two classes of big data problem the
first one is batch processing and that's
the idea that you've got a ton of data
at rest and you want to process it
making good use of your existing
infrastructure okay so maybe you have a
cluster machine your to make good use of
those resources to produce some
information based on data at rest so
let's say for example you want to
calculate a monthly payroll right so you
take all your database of you know
employees the salaries and once a month
you produce the pay slip that's an
example of a batch processing job the
data is at rest if you have to train a
machine learning model you know maybe
you go fancy and you go deep learning
you go all those images sitting
somewhere again the data is at rest and
you train your model on it that's batch
processing you want to make good use of
the resources you have in your structure
so different servers different computers
with different hardware characteristics
and coordinate them to produce a result
and again in the final services
compliance is really exciting and really
hot
and you know for example you may wish to
take the invention all your trade orders
and produce the appropriate compliance
so again the data is at rest okay so
you're not so concerned about the
latency so how fast the thing executes
and you get the result what your concern
about is making good use of the
resources available to produce the
result and often volume is the concern
and variety you might have a ton of
different things like lock files JSON
files spreadsheets and you need to kind
of merge it all together to produce some
insights
now the other class of big data problem
is called stream processing and hey the
concern is often the the latency so how
fast do I get a response to a specific
query so you typically have an SLA that
you need to be able to manage so in
terms of you know hundreds of
milliseconds so for example if we have a
bank transaction surfing there's the
latest stripe yesterday I was talking
about fraud detection for stripe
transactions you kind of won't be able
to flag it on the spot whether the
transaction is fraudulent or not rather
than wait a couple of days because the
money is gone right so in this case
latency is very much the concern and
this is even more challenging when you
have high velocity so when you have
millions of transactions are all
happening at the same time how do you
combine velocity and latency together
and there's a lot of kind of maybe newer
technologies that are dealing with
stream processing problems that you see
and SPARC actually can be used for both
batch processing which that's what we'll
focus on today but also for stream
processing and often when you do stream
processing you have to think about time
windows so all the transaction between
you know now and in a second and
aggregate that right so that's gonna be
the intuition so the data is in motion
you've got high velocity and you need
low latency so let's do a little quiz
just to make sure we're on the same page
I've got prizes actually so this is my
book functional programming in Java
appreciates a Python conference
what I hear is often people write Python
good and I could invite them but once
you go to production often some
companies are debating whether the
migrating their code to Java or not
because they can buy into the whole JVM
ecosystem that allows you to monitor
your job and you know do some
performance tuning so Luther prizes so
let's see generate a balance sheet from
all the invoices in a month is there bad
shows that stream batch right the data
is at rest and we need to compute a
balance sheet based on that now provide
real-time alerts to stock market changes
stream right it can it flag now where
it's kind of go down it's gonna go up
whether there's an anomaly and we should
think about some strategy though the
PageRank metrics for the web so the
PageRank you know the classical
algorithm invented by the Google
co-founders to tell you how popular a
relevant website a web page is right and
the way that's calculating calculated is
by aggregating multiple websites and
page together the link tank to this web
page so that virtue is that stream ah
yeah it could be both so let's think
about it
so in practice a lot of problem can be
both if you think about it right so the
reason you may say it's bad it's because
the input to this function to calculate
the page right is basically the Internet
that's pretty crazy if you think about
it here's the whole internet indexed and
will calculate the number based on that
so the data is at rest now indexing the
Internet is you know text five right
because there's a ton of data so in PI
it's a batch processing job the ideal is
that PageRank metric for every website
is continuously being updated as the
internet evolves and people post new
links and so on so we'd like it to be a
stream processing job but from an
engineering point of view because you're
dealing with the internet there's always
some sort of latency so it'd be
classified as a batch processing job
instead now you can be really clever
with incremental updates and stuff and
then it gets a little bit
confusing when it's bachelor stream but
you know you can think it about this
problem as both batch and stream and the
last one so by doing machine learning
for cybersecurity really hot as well
tons of money so I'm normally detection
in network traffic streaming potentially
could be both in practice you want to be
able to flag whether you have some sort
of intrusion anomaly like on the spot so
you can react to it it could be a batch
processing job if is a log of network
traffic and then you need to do some
analysis on it but if you need to detect
our maybe we're firewall rule then
you'll be classed as a stream task cool
awesome everybody so that's kind of the
the big data landscape that two main
classes of problems now what I'm going
to do in this tutorial is to focus on
batch processing using spark so let me
introduce the Hadoop ecosystem and the
technologies available that you often
hear about and then we'll get hands on
and get coding so how do we deal with
big data well we take Anthony's computer
some processing you know and it's too
slow we're unable to cope with the
business requirement so what's the next
thing we do if we want to speed some
tasks
what's the immediate option available to
us yeah more power yeah go bigger great
so skin up whoo
so if you got money that's great and
there's a very good reason why this is
the thing you always most cases want to
be doing the same code that you write on
one machine in Python it's going to work
on a more improved version of that
machine right so maybe the frequency is
higher
you've got multiple cores you add more
RAM you've got SSD you go bigger the
same code will run and that's fantastic
you don't need to do any configs any
setup all that kind of stuff right so
often scaling up its the is this
solution that is recommended in terms of
solving the problem it's really easy to
do that these days with cloud services
right in the click of a button you can
upgrade a machine right and you might
want to rent it out for such a number of
days or hours depending on what
processing you need to do so that's the
fastest thing you can do now eventually
you hit a ceiling and it gets
increasingly more expensive just to add
a little bit of performance so if I was
to draw a curve you know the return
investment goes like that she wants just
an incremental performance improvement
so the next thing we can do is to scale
out so everyone in this room we're going
to use all the computers and somehow
we're going to coordinate split the jobs
merge it and hopefully solve the problem
right that's the next solution and
obviously there are trade-offs for those
solutions so on the left hand side you
have high usability you know you can
code on one computer great you know
pandas we love pandas or spark I'm going
to mention in a bit and it's just words
sheep on the right hand side you get a
lot of power potentially infinite we can
scale out on demand however it's a lot
more complicated to deal with a lot of
machines as opposed to one so no the
classic business intuition if you're
managing a team you know often it's
easier to work on your own then like
with ten people like suddenly have to
coordinator who this work interview one
on one they were nuts right so that has
a lot more overhead as well to solve a
task so that's the trade-off
now you first you draw a list of pros
and cons scaling up is my favorite one
because it's the same programming model
I don't have to worry I can just run the
same code I don't need to change it
but often from a business point of view
means you're investing to a high upfront
costs so we have to buy into more
powerful machine nowadays with client
services obviously that's less of a
concern you can have more power on
demand so that's good you have a single
point of failure so if that machine goes
down you're stuffed so and you have a
ceiling in terms of how much performance
you can get right just based on current
physics now scaling out is more
difficult to use again because we have
to coordinate split the work merge it
together and we'll talk about spark
potentially is cheaper we can get a lot
of cheaper machines to work together as
opposed to investing into one larger
machine that's more expensive you get
flexibility so we can adapt with the
demand so you know if you think about
Twitter you know when there's a football
game you know people tweet so you know
we can get more machines to process the
sweets if it's a quiet day you know it's
raining and everyone's home then you
know you can scale down the number of
hosts to do the processing right so
that's what you get you get an
elasticity property so where does the
Hadoop ecosystem comment so wouldn't be
nice if we had the best of the two
worlds like usability and power that's
kind of what we love to have so what
Hadoop ecosystem is all about is a set
of technologies that gives you the
illusion that you're working with one
machine or one unified interface burn
under the hood you have a distributed
system all right and that's the only
thing I had a criticism is about and
obviously it's it gets a little bit more
complicated because there's multiple
concerns when you actually need to do
some soft computational work so here's
like three layers that you can think
about so if you need to process data you
have to store these data somewhere
that's like the first thing so if I
think about my macbook pro here you know
running my quest then I've got a file
system that
mr. data so how can we get a file system
that allows me to store data on a
cluster of machines right and that's
called a distributed file system and
HDFS which stands for the Hadoop file
system is an example of a distributed
file system so you'll get an interface
read and write for files but the data is
stored across multiple machines there is
full tolerance so certain slices of
files will be copied over several
machines when you try to read
they'll be smart enough to realize whew
I can get a slice from here and in
parallel I can get another slice from
here and load them up right so that kind
of stuff is abstracted away for you with
HDFS so that's that's good and you know
Amazon if use s3 you know a lot of
vendors have their own proprietary you
know distributed file system this is the
hard one now the next level of in that
layer is we can think about say yarn
isn't a great acronym for dinner parties
like what does they even mean so it
means yet another resource negotiator
the tech industry always comes up with
like random stuff so you know on my
machine here I need an operating system
that is capable of dealing with the
resources available on my computer so
the memory the CPU may be a GPU as well
if we go fancy right so we also need
this idea of an operating system for a
distributed system right now that's
often called a cluster manager so that's
going to decide alright I know the
resource available my cluster and I can
allocate certain resource to execute
certain jobs right so that's yon and as
other management meses is also a popular
one they may hear about now the next
layer is actually how do we execute some
work like I just want to write code
right like so what happens so that's the
data processing layer and there's two
data processing engine
that a lot of people talk about we'll
talk about desk as well so there's a
tutorial later on about desk and I'll
come back to this topic in a bit so
you've got MapReduce which is really old
obsolete not like terminator who is not
old who is old but not obsolete and
Apache spark so what those guys are
going to try and do is say well alright
I'm going to let you as a developer in
it they decide to specify a task and
that's gonna get scheduled on that
cluster using Hadoop beyond its gonna be
able to read and write data using the
Hadoop file system so how do we compare
those two things it's crazy to think
that MapReduce was only released in 2011
I just can't believe that it's only
seven years ago it's just legacy
so what reduce again is just a
distributed processing engine starting
11 has only two operations available map
and reduce lets you specify any kind of
tasks so there's a bit of a problem here
because the the reality in the world
that we deal today there's a ton of
operations that we may wish to do you
know like you're doing pandas things
like filter apply grouping reducing you
can create a rich list of operations but
no we've not reduced you have to fit
within that framework and on top of that
the way the implementation works if you
have to stage an output of one function
to become the input of a next one it's
written to to disk and then gets loaded
back in for the next operation so
there's a high i/o cost so as soon as
you know you exchange data over the
network you write it to this it's super
super slow so MapReduce doesn't perform
very well so spark came about three
years later and address some of those
issues so there's a rich set of
operations which means as a data
scientist you can write code there it's
closer to the problem statement or the
business requirements and on top of that
it's going to try to execute as much
work as possible in memory before it
gets exchanged between several machines
right so that's how we can reduce the
performance bottleneck
so here's the benchmark you know
benchmark it's only one benchmark right
but spark definite performs a lot better
than MapReduce and is widely adopted by
most large financial companies and other
companies today so if you're not
familiar with MapReduce as a concept I'm
just going to explain the intuition so
really the problem we want you to solve
is how can I split a task and get
several machines to work on those tasks
independently so that I can get as much
hell as them as possible right so I'm
gonna grow up Anthony what's your name
Jack and Anthony Jack and Joe great so n
myself well right so suddenly you know
we give in a list of transactions from a
bank and we have to process it to find
out the monthly spent well it's less the
task that we need to solve so where do
we start cuz we for people so vertically
we could get that job done four times
quicker that's the ultimate goal right
so the map step is saying okay Jack
you're going to get a subset of the data
juhi get a subset of data and Tony same
for you and my server so we split in
four now the first operation to execute
is probably some sort of extraction
given transaction how do you get your
mouth how do we do some conversion
because the transaction might be you
know in EU in GBP in Chinese year and
etc so we got to convert it to dollars
so there's a bit of CPU work to do and
that's map so map says there's the
function that you need to apply on the
subsets of data it's completely pendent
so all of us here we can do that work
completely independently and that's
awesome like that's the best that you
want you to have because there is no
overhead to communicate and share
results so you get a great reduction in
latency now at some point because we
found an intermediate result we don't
have the monthly spend yet we all have
some information about it we're gonna
have to kind of coordinate to merge it
together
and that's called the reduce step what
reduce means is you know we're gonna
have to decide I know you and I are
going to do that final kind of merge so
I've got a quarter of the information
you have a quart information you've
calculated the total for that quarter
and then you know I hand over to you and
now you get a half and you to do the
same you also get a half so that's
called reduce because we went from four
to two and finally you guys decide who
does the final half right and then we
have the final result and that's how you
get parallelism so MapReduce is
applicable both in the context of
multi-core programming where you get
different threads though during the
working panel or in the context of
distributed system where instead of a
thread of a machine right now in
practice what happens is normally you
get distribution where each machine is
also multi-core so carry this concept it
trickles down but that's the MapReduce
pattern and that's why it's so popular
in functional programming and in
parallel programming cool so that's it
for the Hadoop ecosystem hopefully
everyone gets an idea of what it is and
what we're going to do now is to spark
so spark is again a distributed
processing engine and we're going to
focus on batch processing so let me
introduce park now before we get a
notebook going so spark is really a
unified data processing engine the
reason I say unified is because it
supports multiple data sources so spark
is really useful when you have
unstructured data for example you might
be log files so all the HTTP logs in a
web server there isn't structure per se
there isn't like a scheme are you gonna
draw is just text right so you could
load all those log files into spark and
start to do some work right also allows
you to interact with things are a bit
semi structured I guess like JSON so
JSON files can
have a schema or they come a lot of
optional attributes so you can look at
JSON into spark you can plug smog into a
relational database as well right so any
sort of data sources you can read that
into spark and your spark as your
distributed processing engine
now spark is supported by multiple
programming languages that's definitely
a great win when your large company and
you want to buy into a technical
solution because often you might have a
team of developers that use a Java for
example right so if they know Java
that's great they can you Spock you may
have people that know Python that's
great they can know you also use Spock
so there's a Python API Java API scholar
and nobody uses R so don't bother but
that everyone should use Python this is
PI data after all it's not our data so
I'm just kidding of course
now so now let's say you've got Python
and you've got a different data sources
that you want to plug in so what's
available so there's different
components within the SPARC project that
you can use so today will focus
specifically on spark a core so the RDD
api that allows you to plug in into
unstructured data and also structured
data but you've got things like data
frames so if your data has a schema and
you want to run cycle like operations
then the data frame API is really
performant because there is a known set
of operations you can run sequel on
SPARC you can do streaming so things
like windows slicing so you know to
batch up transaction of seconds or five
transaction over time those windowing
operations are available streaming you
can do distributed machine learning so
there's ml lab which is a bit old now
this Spock ml which kind of the newer
version you can run graph queries as
well using graph X so it's a fairly rich
set of tools that allows you to do data
processing depending on what the shape
of your data is so how does
work under the hood so here's a bit like
the lifecycle when you want to run a
spark job so always starts with a driver
program so that's like the the program
that's gonna launch the job right so we
call that the driver program and the
driver program has to set up what we
call a spark context so that's the entry
point to using this block API so later
in the notebook that you walk through
you'll see a spark context right so
that's the entry point to run queries
now the spark context is going to
interact with the cluster manager and
the cluster manager is going to deal
with resource allocation schedule
different jobs on those machines are you
gated back and then send the information
back to the spark context okay
now I just want to spend a bit of time
on high spark and put a big caveat we're
using Python do not expect the same
performance as using the Java API
because there's a ton of wrapper and
things are happening in the hood sighs I
said spark is a Java project runs on the
JVM right now if you write Python code
and suddenly we need to execute
despite some code on JVMs the you know
set up on each machine my cluster
there's going to be some sort of
serialization so we're gonna have to
convert the Python object world into the
Java object world right and that's
expensive because you waste CPU in doing
the conversion and you waste
memory location and memory access for
kind of interacting with this utilized
data so PI spar is always going to
perform worse than just using the native
Java API just because there's a lot of
memory overhead to do this civilization
now I have to say some of that is thing
we do so the Python API is going to try
to do as much processing as possible in
Python and reduce that data in Python
before gets exchanged to be run on the
JVM so there's a little bit of smartness
that is going on ultimate
there's a lot of overhead for converting
between Python and Java right so not
only that even worse when things blew up
when things go wrong you're gonna see a
nice Java exception a Java stack trace
because the job runs on the JVM right so
there's out of memory error or there's
some problem in your data then you see a
big fat German exception you might be
like whoa like I don't know Java what
the hell is this right which is totally
understandable and this is why I also
encourage you if you're interested in
big data processing to come to the
tutorial on desc
that is happening this afternoon not by
me by another gentleman because dusk is
essentially a full fully Python project
that attempts to be the pandas for
distributed processing and as a couple
advantages here is that if you already a
daily scientists and use pandas the
conceptual migration between that and
desk is fairly trivial because it's the
same API and secondly when you get
exceptions there will be Python
exceptions as opposed to Java exceptions
okay however the JVM is great again in
terms of monitoring profiling it's well
understood has been around for almost
three decades now any company has a java
running somewhere new JVM so it's well
understood there is support available so
those are all concerns that are really
important for production that might be
really cool to play around but you know
it's still an experimental project okay
excellent so that's the theme let's now
look at the spark API so the rgd API and
we'll learn the different patterns
available to get started will process
data on each computers and at the end of
this tutorial I'll show you how we can
take the same code set it up of a
cluster of machine and massively reduce
the latency of a request or deal with
like a large volume okay so just to
learn I was going to work on the
computer but then later on I'll show you
how we can like scale this out seven
sheets so RDD means resilient
distributed they
set another fantastic acronym for dinner
parties and you can think about it as
just a collection of elements so a bit
like you know a Python list but the
beauty is that the the data or the data
being computed is distributed over
multiple machines so that's abstracted
away you get the illusion that you just
see an interface a list under the hood
all those operations that will apply on
an RDD will get scheduled of a clustered
machine ok so really simple if I were to
create an RDD from a applies the Python
world I can use this method called
paralyzed s-see means the SPARC context
she remember the SPARC context is
declared in the driver program that's
entry point using spark that's an object
that you'd be creating if you wanted to
use sparking in the notebook that's set
up for you and that way I get is an RDD
so paralyzed it's not very useful it's
just useful learning and toy example so
in practice you're going to need to load
some data from somewhere and then you
spark as your processing engine so
there's a few methods available text
file that's going to take a file from a
location and each line becomes an
element of your RDD ok so I could
potentially process a large file of a
class of machine should by using text
file
it supports various data source so for
example if I wanted to load a file from
an s3 bucket if using Amazon so s3
allows you to store large files up to
five terabyte you know I could with one
single line of code load up a large fire
from s3 and start using a spark to
process it okay so that's pretty neat
there's very simple operations you know
that you may use the counting we tell
them of elements take returns the first
n elements in your DD first it's just
the first one just a couple of basic
operations to get you started now where
things get more interesting it's kind of
common data processing patterns that you
may be family
using pandas so the first one is filter
so that's a bit like your wear clothes
in in sequel and remember here we
potentially dealing with data is
unstructured coming from locked files
okay so this is why we have those lambda
expressions so those are arbitrary
pieces of code that we want to be able
to run on each element in the RTD so
filter has gonna say well give me all
the names that start with J and you know
we've got Jack and Joe here so that's
pretty convenient so in this case you
know Jackie and Jessica are erroneous
kept I want you to understand that
filter is not a mutable oppression so
it's not changing your data source it's
just filtering those elements out so
we're gonna have a new RTD that has the
elements we never modified the source or
DD or a list right it's just the values
flow tree map allows you to specify one
operation on each element of your input
oddity
so it's be like applying pandas so here
I want to say you know transform each of
the strings to uppercase and you can see
the upper haze all those names are in
application okay excellent so the power
is when you really come move that's
interesting okay
the power is really when you kind of
compose all those operations together
right filter map produced an RDD so you
could change those operations up to
serve a specific business problem now a
flat map is the one that's conceptually
a little harder to grasp at first so if
you come from a functional programming
background flat map is highly popular
the reason is is allows you to specify
one-to-many relationship and mapping so
if I look at map tree you can say from
one input we get exactly one output
right so Emilia I know case we get a
million up case so that's what one flat
map allows you to do one too many so
that could be zero it could
one could be several elements so here
the the method split in Python returns a
list okay so if I do split over I on
Amelia what you'll get is a list with
two elements a male in the first element
and then just a II as being the second
element okay now if I do the same thing
on Jack you know jack is no I so you
just get a list of one element Jessica
you get chest and cap
so what flatmap does is to apply a map
operation so the function I would pass
as an argument here is applied on each
element on the left hand side there
returns a list and the flattened part
flat essentially collapses all those
nested lists into one single or DD okay
so what you get is still a flattened or
DD but clearly we've achieved one too
many mapping here because the result
here has more elements than then the
input okay so that's flat map distinct
allows you to remove duplicates so has a
few operations available and in the
smoke world there is a difference
between transformations and actions the
transformation allows you to produce
another RDD so filter map flatmap
distinct oil-producing oddities and that
means you can change those things up
together to build a rich queries to
solve a specific task and action that's
when you actually trigger this pipeline
of operations to return a single value
so count is an action because you get a
number at the end of it take is also an
action because you get a Python list
idea and and filters and transformation
because that produces an RDD okay so
let's go to the Python notebooks now so
again you can use the Google collab a
link that provided to you you have to
run all those initial cells here so
that's basically setting up JDK
spark downloading the data set setting
up the config so you're ready to go all
right now I'm going to use my local
notebook now to show you what's going on
so this notebook is if you downloaded
the repository from from the get lab
okay so the first thing I'm going to do
here is to set up my spark context so
I'm ready to go okay so now as a little
simple exercise we're gonna have to do
two things - one is create an RDD from
the Python list just get wound up and
then throw this tutorial we'll do a bit
of basic natural language processing on
an essay called war and peace okay so I
see some smiles here so some people know
about one piece that's good so we're
gonna do some bit of mining on that text
so you know just to get started just so
everyone gets an idea so paralyzed as I
said allows you to take a Python list
and turn this into a RDD so we're going
to need Jack Joe okay so that's going to
be an RDD and now if I look at the type
of that what you'll see that that
returns me a PI spark RDD so that's a
class that is built-in into the pie
spark project gets a really zillion
distributed dataset so now using this or
DD you might be tempted to say length of
our DD that's not possible right because
Len works on Python list here we have a
completely different type so we're gonna
have to use the RDD api so or did
account and that's going to produce
three all right
so very simple now things get a bit more
interesting when we can actually load up
some data file and process it again on
one machine at the moment so this is
running locally and then by the old
story I'll show you how we take this
code and set it up this is up over
cluster machine so I can say a text file
as an input get the URL of the file so
we're going to call it
lines right and now I can say lines that
count and what we see there's about
fifty four thousand lines accent so what
I want you guys to do now for like five
to ten minutes and then i'll life code
it is have a go at those learning
activities from basic oddity
manipulation to using filter map and
distinct so all the way here and
hopefully the google collab link is
working out remember you need to say
opening playground run all the cell's
shift-enter to run a song and you should
be good to go so I'll give it five
minutes or so for you guys to have a
play and then I'll walk through if you
got some questions please come here with
your laptop if you need some assistance
and I'll try and help
got that from the Gmail link is there
another place I should go yep so just
type just like this one tablet in your
broker then you should be like all good
to go requires each other gmail account
what she do I think yeah let's see if it
was okay she opening playground come
then shift Anton let's hit run anyway
yes cool
that's setting things up and then you
should be good great thing if this works
I'm so happy
did anyone get the Google collab thing
to work raise your hand
oh my god yes you have no idea how much
hassle
setting up spark has been in the past oh
Jesus okay
Oh God yeah well everybody uses the
collab 1 Y is the get lab ok some sort
of DNS settings which we look into but
you have everything on the collab so
that's all good but it's enough respect
uncle
do not record this can you use that cut
cool so I'm setting things up and I
don't want that to go on YouTube
we passed as an argument a function
that's going to apply to each element so
that function is a predicate he returns
true or false
and then we're going to say war in get
words that line so I can do a count on
that so we can change things up so
that's my war count now we can do the
same for the piece count so take a lines
filter under nine piece in get words
line and can count and then I might wish
to like get an idea of how it compares
and side times piece occurs less
frequently than war so that's not cool
but at least we know how to solve this
problem using filtering counts so we can
apply transformation and then in action
now let's look at map so use much
capitalize each line in the RDD so you
get the lines map get the line line to
oppress we get a one-to-one mapping then
I'll take 15 and again I can you treat
over this result and print it okay so as
you can see everything is in uppercase
also now use fat much credit oddity of
the words in word piece and count the
number of words so that's a little more
tricky so let's try
divide this problem in different steps
so I'm gonna use map first just so we
get an idea of what we might get so if I
use a map right and I do lambda line and
then get the words on that line okay
I'll take the first ten results so get
an idea of what's produced so if I do
this what you'll see is that we get a
list right so this outer square bracket
means we have a list as a result and
then we've got a closing square bracket
here now each element is another list
why is that case the case is because get
words returns a list as we've
established early on so hello and we see
you know if I do type of get words yeah
she returns a list so that's one get a
list of Lists which it's not extremely
useful because if I do a count here we
get exactly the same result that we had
earlier which is the number of lines so
that's not useful right so somehow we
need to go from the list of lists to a
flattened list and that's what flat map
is for so again if I take ten here
we get that let me just use flat map
instead and what you'll see is suddenly
very nice we flattened all those
intermediate list and then I can take
the first ten words now what that means
is the RDD does produce here is
essentially the words and I can do a
word that count and we can see it's you
know larger than the number of lines and
that makes total sense
oh now what about the count of number of
distinguished well we've got a nice
distinct methods to to do that
so I can say distinct and the reason
works is because woods is an oddity and
I can apply transformation of that which
gives me an oddity so distinct and then
I can do a count okay
and then we can see there's about 19,000
unique words in the essay all right
thumbs up everybody cool so I'm going to
cover a couple more queries available
just everyone has kind of an idea of the
set of operations available so it's one
thing to work on one RDD and one file in
practice you'll often need to work with
multiple data sources and combine the
data sources to serve a specific task so
I might have you know customers from one
department that are really interested in
sports and then I'll have another source
of customers they're really interested
in food okay
so I mean which kind of combine those
two sources together in order to do some
business intelligence so how do we
combine two rdd's and to do that you've
got a union method essentially
concatenate two rdd's together okay so
there might be two log files are loading
up or you're reading off this
information from some some database now
intersection works a bit like in set
theory
so here maybe I'm interested in finding
out what are my you know VIP customers
they want a highly engaged because
they're buying from those two
departments so by doing intersection I
can find out that Jessica is available
in both rdd's okay and subtract allows
you to remove elements from an input RTD
so maybe you have like a list of
suppliers you know which is your names
one and you've got some trusted
suppliers that are giving us a an input
and you do your annual review so you
want to have all your suppliers
except the ones that you really trust
right so that's where subtract can be
used so we left with Emilia and Jack
because Jessica was was removed
she's a trusted supplier excellent so
those are a couple of operations that
lets you work with multiple entities
together now all the operations I may
use so we've covered count of cover take
finally there's collect which I haven't
mentioned yet so collect allows you to
take an oddity and get the whole thing
as a Python list now this is an
extremely dangerous operation as an
overdose the reason it's very dangerous
is you basically saying I've got an
oddity that pretentious distributed of a
whole class of machine and thus far
context the driver program saying
awesome just give me all the result
right so if this is potentially a large
amount of information then you'll just
blow up the driver program because all
that data is going to come to one single
machine and leave in memory and that
runs on the JVM so it's highly likely
you have a memory error that will be
thrown at runtime
okay so collect to be used with with
care and practice you shouldn't really
use collect you would dump result into a
file or another data source to read the
results later on reduce reduce is a fun
one and that allows you to merge and
combine intermediate results from
different places and get one output so
let's I don't have a whiteboard so I'm
gonna explain reduce in a cell so we're
going to learn about reduce to two them
down and then
we'll insert another cell all right so
let's say we've got some transactions
transactions equals where's Anthony cool
sorry Anthony what do you like to spend
your money on food great
what do you for breakfast today fruits
that's very healthy so how much do you
think you spend on fruits teas for
intensive breakfast zero what would you
get this deal from are you going from
here like Trevin man free food okay I
like let's I need some numbers from you
so let's go for five dollars a fluid of
fruits kingi you've got a capsule you
buy clothes I guess right so thirty
dollars in clothes you live in New York
what's the rent in New York like too
high thirty hundred awesome
everyone's like where do you get these
deal friend excellent and maybe you have
a gym membership
Yeah right one last thing spend money on
you can't just be fruits and rent yes
I don't fifty dollars in be daily spent
excellent now so that's your
transactions and what I want to do is
you know in practice if you've got
transaction from a bank you know you
have a billions of records right and you
need to process that now I want to be
able to reduce this list into a single
value
maybe the total the maximum the men so
how can we approach this so I'm going to
create a function called reduce it's
going to take some data and then a
combiner and combiner is going to be a
function that abstracts how do we
combine two values together to produce a
result right so what ideally I'd like to
do is to combine five and thirty
and then the result of that combining
1300 and then the result of that
combining 50 right so we kind of do like
a little fold so one way we might
implement this is you know got a result
and one might say well start with the
first element and then for the indeed
then we'll say rest is the combiner of
rest together with the next element in
the in the de saucé and then we return
the result okay so what I've created
here is just a simple function that
iteratively combines each element in
that list produced a new value we use
that value to combine it with the next
one okay so in functional programming
this is called fold because if you take
a sheet of paper which might be your
collection then you know you get those
little squares if you keep on combining
them right and you get one final element
like one little square so the way I
could use that is I could say reduce
here we'll take Antonis transactions and
data and then I need to specify how do
you want to aggregate each of these
elements so here I have a lambda which
t1 and t2 so those two transactions and
I may say let's just combine them okay
so if I run this code what we'll see is
sorry yeah we get our transaction so
it's data defined but let's go so what
we see here is the total of that is 1390
yes where do you see the bug
hey don't you know correct so we'll do
that
oops food
sorry yep yep yep food in data and then
we do that and then there we go so
you're correct so hey my assumption
we've reduced is I'm starting with the
first element right if the data source
is empty then obviously this is going to
blow up because we can never access the
first element so often when you see
libraries that implement reduce there'll
be an option to add a starting element
in the case that your source is empty so
I could default value to use now what's
happening here is that you know we've
started with five we combined 30 you get
35 we combine out of 30 100 we get 1335
and then finally we get 50 but a beauty
with the reduced abstraction is that
instead of passing a this lambda
expression here could decide to pass max
for example and if I run this again
we'll see that the maximum is the rent
in New York or I could say min and then
we'll see that it's actually the spent
on fruits so we've managed to build this
really nice abstraction that essentially
abstract the internal threading model
right we just say this is how you
combine elements I don't care how the
iteration is done in this case it's a
full loop but the same abstraction could
be used to reduce stuff over a
distributed system we just specify what
is the operation to combine those
elements and that's what reduce is a
really powerful function and its
built-in in to spark so it works like
that where reduce is a method so it's
called an on an RDD and then you give it
the operation to combine those elements
cool so I'll give a couple of minutes to
go through some of the remaining
exercises
so you see it as a couple of satellite
transformation reduce and merging
filters so I'll give a couple minutes
and then I'll left CODIS we're running
out of time
good cop so we're running out of time so
I'll just live code a couple of these so
use the function unit sections great
oddity of lines where more piece I
mentioned so we'll have the war lines so
get a lines again we filter lambda 9 we
get war and get words that line then we
get peace lines peace get words line and
then if I want the Union how basically
say what lines union peace lines and I
can do a counter this will get 369 so
that's the lines I have both war in
there and peace and if I do an
intersection then there's only seven and
I could collect them this case and then
we can find what they are so we can see
here try to Russia if I declare war it
will not make peace as so yes we've got
those two words available now the next
one is use reduce to find the longest
word in war in peace so if you remember
we have an oddity of words and that's
essentially we took the lines we flatten
up that and then we left with the words
so I'll do reduce and what reduce get is
essentially an accumulator so that's the
current longest word together with the
next one in the RDD so we need to kind
of decide which one are we going to keep
if we get two words some may say it's w1
if the length of
w1 is greater than the length of W 2
else we return w-2 okay so this is going
to return one of the longest word Saum I
have multiple words I have the same
length but they are also the longest so
this is a decision made so if I run this
then we'll see we are left with
characteristically which is a pretty
long word if you ask me cool now I'm
gonna skip some of that stuff and I'm
gonna come to an example on using pairs
for Dedes and then I'll show you a demo
and wrap this up so I had a student one
day he kind of saw this problem of
finding the longest words raising words
then he did map so at that point you get
a word and nothing he did something like
that word the length of that word okay
so what we're returning here if you look
closely is a tuple alright so that's
just a Python to Paul we're gonna say
low you know one in three that's not too
full of course we're gonna say let's
call that data now if I do data 0 and
get low if i they are 1 then we get 3
right so we kind of have a tuple that's
those two elements so this student
returned a tuple here that contains the
word and the length and then call max on
that it turns out max is a bility method
in in interest part right so when you
run this you get su 2 so the result here
is a tuple with zu + n2 but what's
interesting is we went from an oddity of
elements to an oddity of tuples and that
was possible by using the map
transformation now it turns out the
reason zu is the longest word it was z
and you if you do this in terms of
alphabetic order right it is
the longest word and I think what you
can do with the suppression you can
decide which part of the tuple to use to
calculate the the max so in this case we
get characteristically in the length of
18 so what I wanted to show you here is
that our using spark you know we can
support rdd's of tuples of key value
pairs and there's new operations that
are possible with that group by T and
reduced by key that can be used as well
so here's an overview the spark API and
what I want to do now is to show you
right that's great
we've done this on one computer how does
it work on a cluster of machines so I'm
going to use AWS so that's the Amazon
Web Services you might be using Google
Cloud or you know Mike's officio and
there is a service called EMR what EMR
allows you to do and ss4 elastic
MapReduce it is to create a cluster of
machines where basically you give it a
name you say how many instances you want
on that cluster so mmm tricks large is a
specific type of machine you say you
want 16 nodes let's say then you can
configure the stack so in this case I
want spark I want yarn all those things
that I've mentioned earlier and when you
do that you click on create cluster and
then the nerve stuff happens and we're
in a couple of minutes you have a
cluster machines they set up ok so I was
doing that while you guys were working
on the first set of exercise so if I go
to ec2 that gives me the list of running
instances so you know I've got a bunch
of stuff that Cambridge spark things but
a ton of new machines here and three
x-large that were created on that
cluster now another service in Amazon is
s3 so s3 allows you to store large files
and I've got a bucket here called a
humungous thinner and i've got a Jesus
dump which is essentially about hundred
gigabyte of data so 92 gigabyte so
that's you know Jason text records and
as the data scientist you may have
worked on a sample of that data locally
like we were you know doing and then
suddenly you want to scale your queries
and your processing on the real the real
deal so how do we go about this so
that's where EMR comes in so I've set up
already a cluster you see a PI data in
your cluster and what it gives you is a
couple of links so one is I call
Zeppelin so Zeppelin is just a notebook
that essentially is the interface to
your cluster so you write some code in
spark and the notebook is essentially
your driver program so that's really
nice because the same place them call
you've written you can just like reuse
it and just ruin it on like on a cluster
now the other thing that you get is some
monitoring tools so ganglia here tells
me sort of the resource utilization mic
in my cluster so you can see here I run
some query not too long ago just to see
if things were working so the CPU went
up because I run a query and then I can
see the utilization over my cluster here
you can see there's various spikes
that's because each worker node was
doing some work as I run a query right
so if you spoke notebook you'll
basically see something like that yeah
I'm running a basic query which you
should recognize right through say text
file text the URL to the s3 location so
that's my JSON file and then I'm just
saying count Ryan that's going to return
me the number of records here obviously
I can use filter MapReduce this thinked
flat map Union and section all those
things that you've learned and just run
it on that notebook and gets distributed
over the cluster now you may be curious
why count is so slow you know it took
two minutes to count 126 million record
you got to remember this is just a raw
file right so we don't have any notion
of index
so like this is pre-computed there's
actually another operation called count
approximation that is going to return
the result really fast using the hyper
log algorithm but the beauty of spark
again is you got a ton of various files
in different shape and sizes complete
and structured you've got a unified API
to process it you work on a sample on
your local notebook and then you can
scale it and the click of a button using
EMR
so hopefully you learned something today
so that's the other tutorial just to
wrap things up we are from Cambridge
spark there is in UK in England so we
specialize in data science and machine
learning training special on the
corporate side so do get in touch if
you're interested my colleague Kevin is
going to give a really cool tutorial on
interpretability of mashing learning
models using lime lr5 shap some some
really cutting-edge stuff to explain how
decisions are made when you train a
machine learning model it's in this room
so stick around and yeah thanks
everybody
[Applause]